bela den aufreger als letzter hier in
der runde die am abend vielen dank ja
ich habe mich heute aufgeregt über
christian den denn schon wieder hat
christian lindner kein klares bekenntnis
ausgesprochen zu einer ampelkoalition
ihm fehle die fantasie dazu hat er
gesagt dabei hatte olaf scholz ihm
gerade den gelb rot grünen teppich
ausgerollt sogar mit lindners bestreben
nach einer aktien rente kann sich schon
mal an freunde doch von den kam nur die
kalte schulter wieder einmal muss man
sagen dabei wäre alles so einfach diese
koalition mögliche koalition eine ampel
konstellation hätte eine rechnerische
mehrheit von jetzt 54 prozent also eine
satte mehrheit für ein sehr stabiles
bündnis und programmatisch wäre eine
ampel auch interessant weil drei
verschiedene bereiche ökologie ökonomie
und die zukunft des sozialstaates wären
auch gerade jetzt sehr sehr spannend in
dieser kombination und dass das ge zeigt
die ampel in rheinland pfalz wo unter
der führung von malu dreyer also
unterschiedliche charaktere wie volker
wissing der heutige fdp generalsekretär
und das urgestein der grünen dr bernhard
braun braun sehr sehr harmonisch und
auch erfolgreich zusammengearbeitet
haben obwohl sie sehr unterschiedlich
sind aber es gibt länder ins rheinische
männerfreundschaft mit armin laschet und
irgendwas diese ein traumata der
vergangenen zeit fast hat man das gefühl
hinter verarbeite immer noch das was er
vor vier jahren hier gemacht hat diesen
schnellen hastigen ausstieg aus den
koalitionsverhandlungen zu jamaika doch
dies ist keine zeit für
vergangenheitsbewältigung im gegenteil
es gab einen großen liberalen walter
scheel war das der hat 1969 den mut
zusammengenommen und hat eine
sozialliberale koalition geformt die
erste nach dem nachtisch in der
bundesrepublik deutschland mit willy
brandt 13 erfolgreichen jahre folgten
und mit seinem mut hat sich hier die fdp
hoch auf dem gelben wagen gebracht dass
wir auch nur erfolgssong es wird zeit
für christian lindner das gleiche ich
fand das war glaube ich eine sehr nette
art zu sagen christian lindner soll in
den wirklich ab verheerende
wahlniederlage gehen
am kursus die könnte vielleicht gut
funktionieren im ergebnis aber 90
prozent der fdp anhänger die haben halt
einfach keine lust drauf also ich sehe
nur dass die fdp stetig an
prozentpunkten verliert obwohl es kein
bekenntnis gibt von christian mit heute
haben sich schon wieder zwei
prozentpunkte verloren er wird selber
über es da noch irgendwas muss da
passieren
dass das dass das dass viele leute ich
bin davon überzeugt sieht man ja auch in
den umfragen dass viele leute sich eine
solche konstellation sich wünschen ich
habe diese leute
das ist ja auch in ordnung aber ich
glaube genau wie herbert auf die fdp
wäre wäre schön bescheuert wenn sie das
machen würde es gibt die demoskopie ist
ziemlich eindeutig warum es nicht auch
90 prozent bei 70 prozent der fdp-wähler
ticken er schwarz gelb und linda wäre
schön blöd wenn er das jetzt vor der
wahl machen würde aber selbst wenn es
dann zu einer ampel kommen würde die fdp
könnte sich kaum durchsetzen die würden
nach vier jahren gespart werden
wahrscheinlich würde steuersenkungen
wählen und steuererhöhungen das ist ja
erst an das war schuldenstreit an redet
denn sie manche feinheit ministerin als
die cdu die fdp gescheitert es gab ein
einziges mal in der geschichte der iss
die fdp geschreddert worden das war
nämlich in der zeit von 2009 bis 2013
2013 bei sie dann gar nicht mehr im
bundestag die cdu hat die fdp damals
geschreddert und niemand anders ich habe
in der tat eher sind koalition wichtig
ist dass man jeden koalitionspartner
auch die chance gibt so wie helmut kohl
das zum beispiel früher gemacht hat
deshalb das jeder koalitionspartner auch
mit seine dinge durchsetzen kann das
würde dann auch mal diesen schrecklichen
stillstand ben und wir würden konzepte
auch wirklich mal ausprobieren sowie
armin laschet das zum beispiel in
nordrhein westfalen mit der fdp macht
das ist eine partnerschaft auf augenhöhe
und ich glaube das strebt die fdp auch
für den bund an grünen dem war noch dazu
hole ich frage mich warum soll christian
lender tisches fest steht fest
miteinander
ich bin sagen jetzt ein modell für die
zukunft ich bin davon überzeugt das ist
gut aber auf jede fantasie aber nicht
die phantasie von den wähler und fehler
nicht die phantasie von christian linder
ich verstehe auch nicht warum eigentlich
seine entscheidung damals nicht an der
koalition bei der kollision mitzumachen
2017 als etwas negatives darstellen weil
die fdp gewählt wird um etwas zu
erreichen in der regierung und nicht
nein sie sbb gewählt wegen eltern welche
schwerpunkte die sie darstellt nicht
weil sie an der regierung ist und wenn
christian lender der meinung ist an
diese regierung ist die beteiligung
schlecht und er kann das mit seiner
haltung nicht vereinbaren christian
lindner hat auch ein riesen problem wohl
aber
jetzt frage ich mich doch mal wenn wir
das mal ernst nehmen was immer das sein
damals war eine angela merkel mit
ungefähr 32 prozent die grünen hat man
sagen die acht prozent oder so jetzt hat
der armenische nehme an das passiert zu
23 prozent 24 prozent vielleicht frau
schröder kommt er auf 25 so aber immer
noch sieben prozent weniger als beim
letzten mal die grünen haben doppelt so
viel wie jetzt die fdp nicht viel mehr
wie soll denn verhindert werden was der
grund war von christian lindner beim
letzten mal aus der regierungskoalition
bildung auszusteigen mit einem
verstärkten grünen anteil und einem
geschredderten in diesem fall oder
zumindest dezimierten anteil der cdu ich
danke euch für eure leidenschaft wenn
béla anda christian linder ratschläge
gibt dann wird das irgendwann gebe es
irgendwie vergessen würden danke euch
allen für eure leidenschaft wir streiten
weiter in diesem wahlkampf noch zehn
tage bis zur wahl das war viertel nach
acht hierbei bild live morgen sind wir
zurück hier in dieser tollen
leidenschaftlichen sendung
[Musik]